في اخبارنا الاخرى اعلنت وكاله اداره
الطوارئ في ولايه ميسيسيبي جنوبيه
الولايات المتحده ارتفاع عدد قتل الاعصار
الذي ضرب الولايه الى 26 هذا ولا تزال فرق
البحث والانقاص تواصل عملها بحثا عن
المفقودين وجثث الضحايا وامر الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن بتقديم مساعدات
فيدراليه للمناطق المنكوبه متعدا بوضع كل
الموارد المتاحه تحت تصرف الولايه لاغثه
المتضررين وتسبب الاعصار الذي اجتاح مناطق
شاسعه من الولايه بخسائر ماديه جسيمه
وحرمان الاف السكان من التيار الكهربائي
قبل ان يشق طريقه نحو ولايه الاباما
المجاوره التي تستعد لاحوال جويه سيئه
معنا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره محمد العلمي
محمد
اخر حصيله هذه
الكارثه الطبيعيه وماذا عن المساعدات
الفيدراليه التي امر الرئيس بايدن
بتقديمها الى المناطق المنكوبه
نعم وسيله بالنسبه
لعدد ضحايا حتى الان 26 كما اشرت قبل قليل
وهو رقم ربما مرشح لارتفاع بنسبه لحجم
الدمار الذي خلفه الاعصار في المنطقه
بالنسبه للرئيس بيضا اعلنها في الساعات
الاولى من صباح اليوم حاله الطوارئ وهي
اليه اداريه بيروقراطيه من اجل
وضع اليد على مبالغ ماليه دون الرجوع
الروتيني الى الكونغرس من اجل مساعده او
الاضافه المساعده الفيدراليه الى
المساعدات المحليه
الرئيس بايدن تعهد في بيان مكتوب
انه سيقدم كل المساعدات الممكنه وستبقى
الحكومه الفيدراليه موجوده مهما
تكلف ذلك من وقت
وجهد وبدا بالفعل في افاده كبار مسؤولي
الحكومه الفيدراليه من وزير الامن الداخلي
الى المسؤولين عن وكاله الطوارئ
الفيدراليه يذكر ان هذه المنطقه واحده من
اكثر المناطق في الولايات المتحده فقرا
وتعرضت لواحد من اسوا الظواهر الطبيعيه
للتدليل على ذلك مثلا ان عدد القتلى الذين
سقطوا حتى الان يفوق ما سقط من قتل خلال
العام الماضي بكامله جراء الاعاصير
وينتظر كما اشرت وسيله الى ان المنطقه
والكثير من الولايات المجاوره ربما تونسي
جورجيا توجد هذا اليوم وهي تنتظر وتحت
رحمه اعاصير وسوء احوال جويه
فرق الانقاذ مازال تزال تبعث عن المفقودين
وجثث الضحايا مما يرش حرب مع عدد الضحايا
للارتفاع للاسف شكرا جزيلا لك محمد العلمي
مراسلنا
من